ha llegado el momento de hablar de
economía Mi nombre es Ángela Gómez y
conmigo Juan Pablo lucumí Juan Pablo
Buen día para usted Buen día Ángela Cómo
está todo todo muy bien Juan Pablo y
bueno ustedes el experto hoy vamos a
hablar de un tema que ha estado rondando
mucho las noticias y es concretamente la
nueva ley laboral en el estado de la
Florida que tiene en vilo a los
inmigrantes indocumentados Así es Ángela
pues miles de trabajadores extranjeros
enfrentan una incertidumbre por cuenta
de esta ley que entra en vigencia en
julio próximo y que impedirá la
contratación de indocumentados la norma
fue promovida por el gobernador del
estado y ahora aspirante a las primarias
republicanas para la presidencia ron de
santis un análisis hecho por Florida
policy institute dice que esto no sólo
tendrá consecuencias en los inmigrantes
sino en la economía y que los sectores
más afectados serían la construcción los
servicios el sector del alojamiento
comercio minorista
y entre otros todos en conjunto
representan el 25% del pib del Estado
solo en labores del campo por ejemplo
hay más de
391.000 empleos en juego pues mire Juan
Pablo aquí cabe preguntarse qué tanto
este fenómeno de esta nueva ley que
aprobaron va a generar un Éxodo de mano
de obra hacia otros estados que sería
digamos lo esperable Así es eso es lo
que se tendría que ver y pues podría ser
muy probable si se tiene en cuenta que
esta ley va a exigir las empresas Pues
con más de 25 empleados verificar el
estatus migratorio de sus trabajadores
quienes al no tenerlo podrían migrar
hacia otros estados con normas más laxas
este filtro deberá hacerse a través del
sistema Every de lo contrario las
compañías quedarían expuestas a multas
de hasta $1000 por día la consultamos al
profesor de la escuela de negocios de
Georgia de Estados Unidos Julio Sevilla
puede que tenga un efecto dominó en la
percepción de los inmigrantes pueden
haber familia donde algunos tienen
estatus otros no tienen estatus la
familia entera se puede mudar Y puede
que trabajadores en el futuro no
regresen Así que yo creo que puede tener
un impacto devastador en Industrias
importantes como la construcción como el
turismo como las contrataciones no de
para limpieza para cuidar niños
en todo tipo de actividad económica en
Florida veremos trabajadores
indocumentados algo que también hemos
reseñado mucho en nuestros informativos
es que esta nueva ley podría incluso
tener una afectación importante para
Florida que tendría mucho que perder
Ángela Pues es que Estados Unidos ya es
un país que especialmente después de la
pandemia ha enfrentado escasez de mano
de obra sobre todo en un estado tan
Dinámico económicamente como Florida
nuestro invitado nos Explica qué podría
pasar cuando comiencen a regir estas
medidas
yo creo de que sí de por sí el país
Estados Unidos ya tiene una escasez de
mano de obra ahí cerca de diez millones
de plazas laborales que están abiertas
mucho hay muchas razones está de la
calificación de algunos trabajadores
pero también la cantidad de trabajadores
Y muchos dicen de que es porque está hay
menos inmigrantes a pesar de que a veces
la cobertura es de que el país no está
recibiendo un gran número en general no
es tan grande como podría ser haber sido
en otros tiempos Así que yo creo que
puede haber una escasez de trabajadores
en la mayoría de las personas saben en
Estados Unidos y hay encuestas que hacen
esta pregunta que los trabajadores
indocumentados o los inmigrantes en
general hacen los trabajos que las otras
personas no quieren hacer no quieren
trabajar quizás en la construcción
haciendo trabajo físico bastante pesado
el limpieza en los campos recogiendo
las diferentes cosechas
quizá Pues con un salario más más bajo
Ángela pero también el análisis Hay que
hacerlo a futuro como lo Explica el
profesor Julio Sevilla
Definitivamente hay acerca de once
millones de de indocumentado en el país
ellos son consumidores también No solo
son ellos sino que es como son gente
jóvenes Generalmente estos tienen hijos
que ya son ciudadanos norteamericanos
entonces podría verse en una situación
difícil que muchos de estos trabajadores
se vayan Así que hay un impacto en el
consumo del crecimiento económico Podría
tener que llevarse a sus hijos también
entonces
representa un problema para el consumo
pero creo que también para el recurso
humano en el futuro ya que el la
población Estados Unidos si no fuera por
la migración sería sumamente avanzada
como en muchos países de Europa son los
inmigrantes los que son la fuerza
laboral del presente pero también están
aportando a la fuerza laboral del futuro
que que son sus hijos no y ha nacido en
Estados Unidos así que también Podrían
haber este tipo de consecuencias
trabajadores del futuro incluso ya ha
nacido en el país tenga que abandonar el
el país no Juan Pablo Ya para ir
cerrando concluyamos con las cifras que
nos dan cuenta de esta situación Ángela
segunda Florida police institute este
sistema de control de contratación de
indocumentados y verify puede costarle
caro A ese estado en términos de
crecimiento económico pues
específicamente unos 12.600 millones de
dólares en un año esa sería la cifra
además el Instituto Calcula que los
indocumentados aportaron 923 millones de
dólares en impuestos a ese estado en
2019 y ahora se dejarían de percibir
pues mire Juan Pablo Le agradezco
ampliamos un poco la perspectiva sobre
esta y otras noticias que Seguiremos
conversando en durante nuestras Crónicas
de economía de la semana seguramente
aquí en economía lo veremos Muchísimas
gracias a ustedes gracias a nuestros
televidentes por acompañarnos una vez
más y sigan en France 24 hay más para
ver